joining us is dr celine gounder a member
of president-elect joe biden's covet-19
advisory board she's an epidemiologist
and
infectious disease expert at the nyu
grossman school of medicine
and bellevue hospital center here in new
york dr gander good morning thanks for
being with us as we just saw california
is again going into regional lockdowns
how effective a strategy do you think
that is
so you know i think we are unfortunately
having to
look at restricting certain activities
dialing
up some of these restrictions around
dining around other
group activities we know that when you
are
indoors when you are crowded amongst
other people
uh and when you're not wearing masks
that increases the risk of transmission
so unfortunately given how out of
control the virus
is at this point we are having to dial
up some of those restrictions again
uh dr gunner we should just tell viewers
about your shot is frozen which is why
we're not looking at you but we can
still hear you
do you think other states should should
take this kind of measure if they're in
similar situations
well i think ideally we should be more
proactive than this
where we don't find ourselves in a
situation where the virus is
to this degree out of control
unfortunately
not everybody decided to stay home in
their household bubbles
to wear masks to socially distance
to have activities outdoors versus
indoors over the thanksgiving holiday
and we're now seeing the resulting surge
from that the chief scientific
advisor for operation warf spree warp
speed dr slowy
says he plans to meet with the biden
team this week
to discuss a distribution of a vaccine
what do you need from dr slowly to
ensure a smooth transition
well we really need to understand what
their plan for distribution is
we've already been trying to get a
handle on
how many doses will be available to us
from each of the companies and by when
but we do need some internal information
on that from the federal government
we also need to understand where they
are with their plans it's
not enough to acquire the doses of the
vaccine to purchase the doses
you also need to have a plan to
distribute them all the way down to the
level of the health care provider the
nurse
who's going to inject that dose of
vaccine into somebody's arm
and so we really need that level of
granular
detail on where they are with the
vaccine distribution planning
and you haven't gotten any of that yet
we have yet to see any kind of detailed
plan
what is your biggest concern regarding
the distribution of the vaccine
well i think a couple one we want to be
sure that there will be enough doses
as have been promised we know that we're
not going to be able to vaccinate
everyone all at once but we need to have
some realistic projections so that we
can prioritize the doses that we have
accordingly and we really want to make
sure
we're vaccinating for maximum impact we
want to be preventing
deaths and we want to be preventing
transmission and you can't really make a
plan for that if you don't know what
tools you're working with
quickly dr gander we heard dr dr burke
say this is the worst event the country
will face
what do you expect in the next few weeks
here before christmas
well sadly uh you know hospitals are
over one run
i think that is going to get worse
frankly over the next couple weeks
i am still seeing patients i know my
colleagues are
really burned out from being on the
front lines fighting this for months
and now they're being asked to see that
many more
patients they themselves may not be able
to take time off over the holidays
and that's going to contribute to
burnout as well
and i think unfortunately some americans
may
continue not to follow the public health
guidance
that we had offered before thanksgiving
and that may lead to further
transmission over the upcoming holidays
dr celine gander thank you very much for
joining us this morning we appreciate it